the outpost is 30 miles over those hills  let's move out who are we babysitting  this time not a who  a mansion house a house the outside  speaking of my whole neighborhood at  Queen's supposed to be a big deal when  the 82nd airborne came through and  pushed out the Nazi High Command this is  a live portion you hear that  We Need to Talk we stay here in fishing  barrel we're staying what's that I found  it in the basement belonged to one of  the Nazis who took over the house it  says what happens the family who lived  here they same right man this place is  bad juju I'm just gonna say what we're  all thinking here this place is haunted  everything we experience  it's what the Nazis did to the family  that lived here let's get out of this  house  they're here I want everyone carried up  and ready to clear out you can't leave  it won't let us leave this isn't real  this isn't real this isn't real this  isn't real  you  [Music]  you